can you give an overview of what gpt3 is
or like you say in your twitter bio gpt
n plus one
how it works
and why it works
so um gpt-3 is a humongous neural
network
and let's assume that we know what is
neural network you gave at the
definition
and it is trained on the entire internet
and just to predict
next word so let's say it sees part of
the
article and it the only task that it has
at hand it is to say what would be the
next word
what would be the next word
and it becomes
a really exceptional at the task of
figuring out what's the next word so you
might ask
why would this be an important task why
would it be important to predict what's
the next word
and it turns out that a lot of problems
can be formulated
as a text completion problem so gpt is
purely
learning to complete the text and you
could imagine for instance if you are
asking a question
who is a president of united states
then gpt can give you an answer to it
it turns out that many more things can
be formulated this way you can format
text
in the way that you have sentence in
english
you make it even look like a some
content of a website uh elsewhere which
would be teaching people how to
translate things between languages so it
would be en colon
text in english fr colon and then you uh
and then you ask people and then you ask
model to to continue and it turns out
that the such a model is predicting
translation from english to french the
crazy thing is that
this model
can be used for way more sophisticated
tasks so you can format text such that
it looks like a conversation between two
people and that might be a conversation
between you and elon musk and because
the model read all the texts about elon
musk
it will be able to predict elon musk
words as it would be elon musk it will
speak about colonization of uh mars
about sustainable future and so on and
it's also possible to
to even give arbitrary personality to
the model you can say here is a
conversation with a friendly ai bot
and the model uh will complete the text
as a friendly ai bot so i mean
how do i express how
amazing this is so
just to clarify
a conversation generating a conversation
between me and elon musk
it wouldn't just generate
good examples of what elon would say
it would get the syntax all correct so
like interview style you would say like
elon cullen and lex like it's not just
like uh
inklings of uh
semantic
correctness
it's like the whole thing grammatical
syntactic
semantic
it's just really really
impressive uh generalization
yeah i mean i also want to you know
provide some caveats so it can generate
few paragraphs of coherent text but as
you go to
longer pieces it it actually goes off
the rails okay if you would uh try to
write a book it won't work out uh this
way what way does it go off the rails by
the way is there interesting ways in
which it goes off the rails like
what falls apart first
so the model is trained on the all the
existing data
that is out there which means that it is
not trained on its own mistakes so for
instance if it would make a mistake then
uh i kept so to give give you an example
so let's say i have a conversation
with a
model pretending that is elon musk
and then i start putting some i'm start
actually making up things which are not
factual mm-hmm
um twitter
but i gotcha sorry yeah um okay
i don't know i would say that elon is my
wife
and the model will just
keep on carrying uh it on and as if it's
true
yes
and in some sense if you would have a
normal conversation with elon he would
be what the [ __ ]
yeah there would be some feedback
between so the the model is trained on
things that humans have written
but through the generation process
there's no human in the loop feedback
correct
that's fascinating makes sense so it's
magnified it's like the errors get
magnified and magnified right and it's
it's also interesting
i mean first of all humans have the same
problem it's just that we
uh we make
fewer errors and magnify the errors
slower i think that actually what
happens with humans is if you have a
wrong belief about the world as a kid
then very quickly you will learn that
it's not correct because you are
grounded in reality and you are learning
from your new experience yes
but do you think the model can correct
itself too
won't it through the power of the
representation
and so the absence
of
elon musk being your wife
information on the internet want to
correct itself
there won't be examples like that so the
errors will be subtle at first
saddle at first and in some sense
you can also say that the data that is
not out there is the data which would
represent how the human learns
that's an and maybe
model would be trained on such a data
then it would be better off how
intelligent is gpt 3 do you think like
when you think about the nature of
intelligence
it seems exceptionally impressive
but then if you think about the big agi
problem
is this footsteps along the way to agi
so um let's see it seems that
intelligence itself is there are
multiple axis of it and
i would expect that the
the systems that we are building they
might end up being super human on some
axis
and sub-human on some other axis it
would be surprising to me on all axis
simultaneously they would become
superhuman
of course people ask this question is
gpt a spaceship that
that would take us to moon or are we
putting a building a ladder to heaven
that we are just building bigger and
bigger ladder and we don't know in some
sense
uh which one of these two which one is
better
i'm trying to i like stairway to heaven
it's a good song so i'm not exactly sure
which one is better but you're saying
like the the spaceship to the moon is
actually effective correct so people who
criticize gpt yeah they say yarga is
just
building a
taller a ladder
and it will never reach the moon
and
at the moment i would say the way i'm
thinking is this like a scientific
question and i'm also in heart i'm a
builder creator and like i'm thinking
let's try out let's see how far it goes
and so far we see constantly that there
is a progress yeah
so what do you think
gpt-4
gpt-5 gpt n plus one
will um
there'll be a phase shift like a
transition to a place where
we'll be truly surprised then again like
gpt3 is already very like truly
surprising the people that criticize
gpg3 as it's there as a what is it
ladder to heaven i think too quickly get
accustomed to how impressive it is that
the prediction of the next word can
achieve such
depth of semantics accuracy of syntax
grammar and semantics
do you do you think
gpt four and five and six will continue
to surprise us
i mean definitely there will be more
impressive models there is a question of
course if there will be a
phase shift
and
the also even the way i'm thinking about
the about these models is that
when we build these models
you know we see some level of the
capabilities but we don't even fully
understand everything that the model can
do and actually one of the best things
to do is to
allow other people to probe the model to
even see what is possible
hence the
using gpg as an api and opening it up to
the world yeah i mean so when i'm
thinking from perspective of
can there like a obviously various
people are that have concerns about agi
including myself
um
and then when i'm thinking from
perspective what's the strategy even to
deploy these things to the world
then
the one strategy that i have seen many
times working is the iterative
deployment that you deploy
um slightly better versions and you
allow other people to criticize you so
you actually are tried out you see where
are their fundamental issues
and it's almost you don't want to be in
that situation that you are holding into
powerful system and there's like a huge
overhang then you'll deploy it and it
might have a random chaotic impact on
the world so you actually want to be in
the situation that they are gradually
deploying systems
you